On est dans la cité  Dervallières à Nantes
On a vu dans les actualités que ça avait pas mal chauffé en ce moment
On a aussi vu qu'il y avait un lac au milieu
On s'est dit : Go pêcher à l'aimant
Il va falloir chercher des spots à proximité
On a changé de lac, l'autre été vide
Celui-là est un plus haut
On reste quand même à côté de la cité
On va aussi faire le côté là-bas
Premier lancer
Un vélo ?
C'est que ça commence très bien mon petit
On ne le voyait pas du tout
Il était juste au bord
Bah ouais
Ici, il est tellement sale le lac, on ne voit rien
Premier vélo
De la journée
Il n'est pas si vieux
Je pense que le pneus sont encore gonflés
Ouais
Il est clairement utilisable
Oh ! Il y a une pièce en même temps, regardes
Pas que le vélo !
1 centime d'euros
Aie, je me suis fait piquer par des orties
Les pièces on va les mettre là-dedans
Allé, deuxième lancer
Franchement c'est plausible, ils se mettent là-haut et balancent une arme
Un anti vole de vélo ?
Peut-être celui qui va avec
Ca a du sens
C'est un panneau ?
Ouais
Il est vieux lui
Attention, matériel radioactif, ne pas pêcher à l'aimant dans ce lac
Plus sérieusement, "traversée d'engin"
Un couteau rond
Et 5 centimes d'euros
Ce couteau rond, il est très moche
Très, très moche
Coup dur, le pied mouillé là-dedans
C'est horrible
Tu vas avoir des champignons
Et pas ceux que l'on mange avec de la crème fraiche
Laissez un pouce bleu si vous voulez que Quentin ait des champignon sur ses orteils
C'est un critérium
De marque SFR
Il faut vraiment que l'on fasse attention à la qualité de l'eau
Et que Rasta ne boive pas dedans
Il y a un héron qui a pris cher là
Il ne put pas trop, bizarrement
J'ai attrapé quelque chose à environ 5 mètres je dirais
C'est plutôt bon signe
Il y a un poids correct
Oui ! Bien sûr !
Une petite carabine !
On en a déjà faite des comme ça
C'est du classique
Calibre 22LR ou 9mm Flobert
Bien joué
Merci
Je l'ai senti
Je t'ai dit, à distance comme ça, jeté de là-haut
Il fallait au moins en faire une
Ah c'est même qu'on a déjà fait, oui
Une carabine de jardin
Il y a une munition dedans
Ah mince, oui
Elle est trop rouillée
Non
Elle ne sort pas
Tient
On va laisser comme ça
On laisse ouvert
Du coup elle est chargée
Et armée
Non elle n'est pas armée
Mais elle est chargée
9mm Flobert
Bien joué !
Merci !
Une arme !
Ah, la pêche à l'aimant dans les lacs de cités commence bien
Il y a pas mal de reportage où on les vois ces trucs
Ils les cachent dans les cages d'escaliers au cas où
C'est pas bien méchant mais ça peut être létal de près
Ca suffit, ouais
C'est surtout pour impressionner
On l'a vu, elle était chargée
Ils ne l'ont pas jeté pour rien ils devaient s'en servir et ne s'en sont pas servis
Pourquoi ? Ou alors il s'en sont déjà servis et l'on rechargée
C'est possible aussi
Comme il y a une munition à l'intérieur, ce n'est peut-être pas une arme de meurtre, on ne sait pas
En tout cas, on va continuer
C'est ce que je voulais, j'aurai tellement été déçu, Nantes sans arme
Ah ! J'ai quelque chose encore
Oh ! Le coupe boulon
C'est bon ça aussi !
Celui-là est vieux
Pareil, du matériel classique de cité
C'est de la qualité mais là, il est mort
Des munitions 9mm Flobert
Elles sont là
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est gros
Non, non, ce n'est pas des munitions
Attend, c'est quoi ? Des sortes de piles ?
Je suis dégouté
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Si vous avez une idée, dites-le en commentaire
Quand tu as trouvé la carabine, il y avait une femme en haut, elle n'en avait rien à faire
Totalement rien à faire
On est posté au belvédère duquel la carabine a surement été lancée
Vous voyez, il y a de quoi faire de gros lancé car on est surélevé
Quentin a une technique
Une idée lumineuse
Ouais ! De ressortir le petit aimant
Avec la petite corde
Ca va permettre de jeter plus loin
Quand il dit le petit aimant c'est quand même le Terror de chez Maison de la Détection
Même si c'est petit, c'est du très costaud
Le Terror c'est 1000kg ?
Ouais c'est 1000kg de force
C'est celui qu'on recommande au minimum
C'est ça, on recommande le Terror pour débuter la pêche à l'aimant
D'ailleurs si vous voulez vous équiper, n'hésitez pas
Code promo PECHEURDETRESORS  vous offre 5% sur toute la boutique
Tu vas nous faire un lancer ?
Attention à ta GoPro en bas
Rasta veut le sandwich du monsieur SDF qui dort ici
Mais non Rasta, tu ne pourras pas y aller
On va voir si je vais réussir à  tirer au bien qu'on pourrait jeter une arme
Rasta, c'est à ton tour d'appeler la Police
Moi j'en ai marre, ils vont avoir un carnet avec écrit mon nom de partout et dire que je les harcèles
On va les appeler
C'est une petite carabine mais elle est catégorisée
On ne va pas ramener ça, elle n'a aucune valeur
Aucune valeur de restauration
En plus, elle peut être impliquée dans quelque chose de pas correct
Bonjour. - Bonjour
C'est une carabine
Elle a dû être jetée d'en haut
Il y a une munition dedans par contre
C'est un carabine de jardin
Ouais
Ça ne vaut pas grand-chose, c'est du 9mm
Il y a une munition dedans ? Vous l'avez ouvert ?
Oui on l'a ouvert
On a des gants
Vous n'avez pas enlevé la munition ?
Non, on n'a pas réussi
On connait bien
Comme c'est rouillé ...
Vous venez de si loin pour pêcher à l'aimant ?
Ouais, ouais, on est Youtubeur
On traverse l'Europe, on est allé jusqu'à Amsterdam, Bruxelles
Ah ouais d'accord !
Vous êtes d'où ?
De Béziers
Ah oui !
Des armes, on en a trouvé plus de 20 en tout
Je connais un bon spot pour vous, si vous voulez
Ah ! Pourquoi pas
A Atlantis
Atlantis vous aller pêcher que des caddies
C'est quoi votre chaîne qu'on regarde ?
C'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Bah écoutes, bon courage !
Merci, bonne journée
Ils étaient très sympa ces policiers Baptiste
Ouais
Allé Rasta, on bouge
Attention de ne pas glisser
Effectivement ça glisse énormément
C'est un jean non ? Ou un sac plastique
Juste un sac poubelle
Il est vide ?
Ouais
Ouais, juste un sac poubelle
Rasta, j'ai un cadeau pour toi
Regardes
Regardez comme elle est grosse
Je ne la mangerai pas celle là
Elle est énorme
Tu as déjà vu une aussi grosse ?
Non, elle est énorme
Qu'est-ce que c'est Rasta ?
Bon, c'est un bon spot à écrevisses mais pas à ferraille
On va décaler au lac qu'il y a un petit peu plus loin
Allé, go
Donc là, j'ai quelque chose
Qui était bien dans la vase
Ouais
Je l'ai perdu
On va réessayer
J'ai peut-être un bout
Oh ! C'est bon signe
Une clef
Regardes ce que ça a fait remonter là
C'est quoi ?
C'est moche
Encore des clefs
C'est un panneau
Et des clefs
Il y a écrit des choses
Qu'est-ce qu'il a écrit de beau ?
Ribeiro, locataire
C'est des clefs d'immeubles
J'ai encore un truc
Du protoxyde d'azote ?
Ah, quoi que
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est
Etonnant
Un objet intéressant hors de l'eau
Un pot d'échappement, la ligne d'échappement
Surement lié aux vols de pots catalytiques
Pas mal
C'est un peu la mangrove
Je crois que j'ai quelque chose directement
Peut être que c'est du bois
Ne vendons pas le bœuf avant de l'avoir mangé
Bois ou pas bois ?
Ah non, c'est un anti vole
Super, super
Regardez déjà ce qu'on a ici
Un beau petit panneau
Ça c'est du lancé
Oh non, il y a le plot en béton avec
Une pince encore ?
Une vieille clef
Elle est totalement morte
Il y a très peu d'eau mais il y a quand même des choses
Ça va être que des trucs comme ça
Pas mal
Là j'ai quelque chose tout au bout
Je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit une branche
C'est peut être un vélo
Oh non ! UnSe barrière
Encore du mobilier urbain
On a fait le panneau, la barrière
La borne
Qu'est-ce qui nous manque ?
Un anti vole de vélo ?
Sympa
Là j'ai autre chose, au même endroit que la barrière
Ça a l'air plus lourd
J'ai peut-être un peu besoin d'aide
Peut-être une barrière
Plus grosse alors
C'était dans la vase
Ça a l'air plus massif
Je m'en doutais un peu
Coffre-fort !
C'est stylé ça
A mon avis le coin a déjà été pêché mais j'ai tiré vraiment loin
La clôture devait être ouverte il y a 20 ans au moins
Ouais peut être à l'époque
La technique
Il y a une étagère dedans, il y a moyen qu'il reste des choses
Ouais peut-être
C'est bon signe
ça ne sent vraiment pas bon
ça pue oui, de toute façon les cours d'eau en ville....
Ah oui il est long
Ce n'est pas un carré
Et Rasta dort pendant qu'on pêche des coffres forts
Celui là c'est le mien
Je vais te laisser le fouiller alors, c'est trop sale
Nous sommes en plein Nantes, dans un tout petit ruisseau
Comme quoi...
On peut trouver même dans des petits ruisseaux
Pour l'instant il n'y a pas grand chose
Je vais regarder sous le tirroir
On va bien le rincer
Il est vide
J'ai un gland si tu veux
Il est mort
Bon c'est déjà pas mal
Là j'ai quelque chose
Woaw
Pas mal une vieille bèche
Celle là est d'époque
Alors ça...
Ah !
ça c'était de la qualité, je vous le dis
Tu pourras la restaurer Baptiste
génial
Sympa
On aime bien les vieux outils
Ouais ouais
Je l'ai
Wow!
Oh non un couvercle de poubelle
C'est ça qu'on avait pas encore fait
En terme de mobilier urbain
D'accord
C'est original
J'ai cru que c'était R2D2 au début mais non
Encore quelque chose
Est-ce que ce serait pas encore un outil ça ?
Ouais, il me semble
Tu as fabriqué une nouvelle poubelle ?
Ouais j'ai fait une nouvelle poubelle
J'ai rajouté son antenne
Là, un plomb de pêche
Il est en plomb mais je l'ai eu grâce à l'hameçon
Je veux bien le récupérer
C'est sympa, ouais
Il pèse !
Entre 20 et 25 kg
Donnes ta patte
C'est bien
Merci à vous !
De rien !
Salut YouTube
Salut Pêcheur de Trésors
Merci à la ville de Nantes pour le soutien
Ca fait plaisir